mais oui tant de pénélope d'accord je
suis très contente antunes elop
merci pour sa magnifique chapeau c'est
ça bien oui merci encore au revoir ton
pénélope
c'était une pénélope
elle m'a offert cette afro chapeau tout
troué
mais elle a l'air tellement content de
me l'offrir comme quand j'ai quand même
remercier
qu'est-ce que je dois en faire
maintenant c'est toujours pareil chaque
fois qu'elle vit de son grenier
il faut qu'elle me donne ces vieilleries
oh la la qu'est qu'est ce que tu fais
françois tu tues coiffe la pelouse
et bien c'est un peu ça casimir je suis
en train de l'attendre reid ont pas mal
ton chapeau de paille tu trouves away
paris il est vieux et tout troué
peut-être mais moi si je l'avais fait
une rendrait bien service parce que avec
ce soleil de plomb
par moment j'ai un petit peu la tête qui
tourne arbon si tu vois je teins les
change c'est vrai mais contre quoi ce
que tu veux je ne sais pas eh ben tu est
ainsi devenu en échange
eh bien je te laisse tondre la pelouse à
la place verte où tu me prends vraiment
pour un casimir us naïf un parent
question non mais par contre je veux
bien le beau foulard que tu as autour du
cou abada corte amiraux tient le foulard
et tais toi en remercie françois y voit
là chapeau merci
ce foulard est vraiment très beau mais
je ne suis pas du tout sûr qu'il aille
qu'il maillotins bonjour madame bonjour
bonjour casimir on vous amuser bien ou
autisme je m'amuse comme un petit fou et
vous croyez que c'est un jeu de votre
argent
ben pourquoi quasi médaille il ya pas un
âge pour jouer aux bulles de savon un
bon jeu pourra y jouer moi aussi bien
évidemment casimir ont dû longtemps
c'est une belle écharpe un lesparre mais
je ne suis pas du tout sûr qu'elle aille
à un bon jour de boké ah ben là je suis
peut-être à chute tête de ton avis
qu'animé ouais ça c'est vrai elle ne va
pas très bien à ton teint mais par
contre elle ira très bien avec vos
bijoux rose
tu crois oui mais pour briller à ben oui
volontiers ses peluches chavez contre
votre appareil à bulles de savon à bon
nombre avec joue à casimir oui voilà ça
ira très bien avec mon beau costume du
dimanche gérard je la mettrais par
dessus ma cravate
la belle cravate mauve 1 et rouge avec
des petits pois jaunes tu sais ouvert ça
fait sport ça rajeunit ça me rajeunit
raoui je crois que je vais faire des
jaloux merci-facteur howard lumière vous
allez voir je vais vous faire une
démonstration là
[Musique]
non non un peu trop pas trop à hambach
je recommence trouve cette fois j'ai
soufflé trop à droite
j'y arriverai jamais c'est pas facile
j'aperçois monsieur du snob
bonjour monsieur du snob ses fables de
monsieur jean de la fontaine sont d'une
richesse
ainsi nous soutenons c'est toi casimir
tu as fait peur ce n'est des
palpitations
bah écoutez je vous ai dit bonjour une
première fois tout doucement vous n'avez
rien entendu alors j'ai l'ouvrir le
lytro bali trop fort enfin juste milieu
est un don que l'on a au colon n'a pas
non si vous voulez on recommence se
retourne et vous vous allez voir bonjour
monsieur du snow bonjour moto du jeune
homme était parfait mais quel est cet
appareil bizarre je vous avec humilité
n'avoir jamais vu ça c'est un appareil
par faire des bulles de savon au sublime
la science n'arrête pas de progresser
que donnerait pour avoir un objet si
cette valeur il vous plaît vraiment à
beaucoup locaux monsieur duchesneau
si vous voulez se voulait change contre
la belle fleur que vous avez à votre
boutonnière marché conclu
je te donne l'oeil et à moi la phénicie
non
époustouflant à quel parfum
il suffit parfois d'une fleur pour vous
rendre heureux que les belles salut
casimir
merci beaucoup mais pourquoi ce que tu
me dis merci pour cette fleur que tu
m'offres si timide mais je suis très
touché quand on prend la prendre je lis
regardez là encore des gouttes d'eau sur
ses pétales ouais elle est merveilleuse
tiens je te donne à mon bon pour la
peine
merci
j'aurais préféré un double boguey allô
oui c'est julie à bonjour pénélope
signer l'accord
we will est ici un instant je vais vous
dire elle veut parler a longtemps peiné
naples le chapeau jallet sur la tête oui
oui oh il me va très bien
quasiment j'ai foutu n'a rien sur la
tête mais non sans peiner landais mais
c'est pas la peine de tout de suite
olalala ben d'accord d'accord pour
quelle catastrophe alors envie tu as
fait une fête que c'est
mais c'est à cause de nous du chapeau de
temps pénélope un chapeau est devenu un
atout la honte où l'art est devenu un
appareil à bulles de savon à paris à
bulles de savon est devenue une flore
depuis la flore est devenu un bon ben on
va quand même pas recevoir ma tante
pénélope avec un bonbon sur la tête
excuse-moi casino mais je ne suis pas
très bien bon ça ne fait rien et coûte
s'il te plaît roman la fleur je te rends
ton mot mort on ne cherche pas à
comprendre voilà monsieur du snob
visitera rendre mon appareil à bulles de
savon je vous rend votre flamme mais
pourquoi je vais mieux je n'ai pas le
temps vous a expliqué 20h01 c'est ce qui
est un facteur en émoi vite mon foulard
je vous rend votre appareil habitants
vous avez dit [ __ ] me voit l'accusé me
remercie voilà françois france toit pour
catastrophe il n'est plus là bonsoir
voila mon pauvre kazim est passé du
service quitte jamais voilà ton foulard
moi mon roman mon chapeau de paille
alors merci à mon championnat l'histoire
casimir écoute
figure toi que j'étais en train de
tondre la pelouse tranquillement quand
attendre paix des nappes est arrivé
alors quand il m'a vu elle a foncé sur
moi comme une furieuse elle n'a arraché
mon chapeau de paille alors et en me
disant que je devrais avoir honte de
chiper son chapeau de paille un pauvre
casimir us moi j'ai voulu prouver ma
bonne foi en lui expliquant ce qui
s'était passé
elle n'a fermé la bouche en me donnant
une grande paire de claques et puis il
est reparti moi je garde le foulard
septembre peiné lente alors quelle force
de caractère
une vraie casimir ocha
aw
[Musique]